Freddy Footprint's garden.
Freddy works with his feet.
Feet are clumsy.
The flowers are trodden.
The trees are bare and the branches broken.
The air is dirty and the pond is full of rubbish.
Harry Handprint's garden.
Seeds had been sown, trees planted,...
...oxygen pumped into the water.
We know about reducing our negative carbon footprint.
Do you know the power you hold in your positive handprint?
Sow some seeds, plant a tree.
Turn a patio into a flower bed.
Better still, get involved in an eco-restoration project or start your own.
Give the Earth a chance and watch her grow.
Freddy Footprint or Harry Handprint?
Who are you?
Hands up for restoring the Earth.
Text the word "Earth" to 83023 to put your hand up for restoring the Earth.